I think the best business for someone to
start if they've never started a
business before is something that they
already have tangential experience with
so if you look at like y combinator for
example they look for Founders who have
lived with the problem Andor have
industry experience and so if you have
both of those things like the likelihood
that you will be successful with the
Endeavor that you're going in is
significantly higher there's a huge
learning curve to entering any new
industry and if you can just pay down
some of that ignorance tax even if the
opportunity vehicle isn't the perfect
one you will still have a significantly
higher likelihood of winning one of the
big fallacies of your first business is
that it's going to be your last business
and almost never is and so the idea is
like it's much more valuable to get
started on something that you have a
higher likely of success on so that you
can get some faster rewards for the
behavior of getting into business and
then from there get some resources get
some skills and then you can have a
better perspective from which to make a
jump or a decision on what to do next
and at least that's my two cents on it